hey everybody welcome to LED live the
show where we get to share the gospel
with the light of Christ and expose some
darkness and today we have a very
special guest we're gonna talk about
yoga can it actually bring you closer to
God or could it potentially lead you
away find out on this episode of LED
live welcome back everybody we thank you
so much for tuning in if you're new to
our Channel and you like what you see
then go ahead and hit that subscribe
button or the bell notification we'd put
out a lot of content and we are very
excited today to bring to you this topic
of spiritualism yoga how our guests got
involved in this world but first we want
to give a shout out to our patreon
donors thank you so much for supporting
our ministry we also today's topic is
going to be taken from a documentary
that we produced on the spiritualism
behind martial arts and it deals with a
little bit of yoga Eastern mysticism so
you want to check out this documentary
if you have an interest in this subject
and I'd like to introduce to you guys
Jessica Smith thank you so much for
coming on our show praise God praise God
awesome you know it's it's always a joy
to to hear how God has really used you
know maybe something tragic that
happened to you and flips it around to
his glory as we get into this you guys
are going to want to hear this testimony
because when I heard that your testimony
I was like blown away anytime you're
like talking to the spirits or like you
know in communication with them I mean I
think the hair on the back of my neck
kind of goes up so it's weird that
that's actually normal in some people's
lives you know yeah you know I think
everybody's looking for some physical
tangible evidence that God is real and
whenever I hear stories like
this that's what it just pops in my mind
is wow this spiritual warfare is real
and I mean people are in the thick of it
here like it didn't even make the hairs
on the back of my neck stand up because
he has it so cleverly masked as love and
light and it's this beautiful and just
on my path toward enlightenment I'm on
my path toward seeing God it was all
just wrapped in this fake beautiful
package of something that it's not
you know whenever we tackle topics like
this if you kind of look through the
videos on our Channel
it seems like the ones that deal with
this topic get a lot of views and and
you know we've kind of made a lot of
videos and analyzing sort of the
spiritual warfare that happens in movies
and television sort of that underlined
message you know and and perhaps that's
why maybe our audience is also familiar
with these kind of topics but I want to
kind of dive right into this like maybe
we can start back from the beginning and
you can kind of share with us you know
did you have an experience with God as
an early child you know how did you get
caught up in spiritualism sure yeah
questionable but my mom introduced me to
Jesus at a young age and really taught
me Jesus is God and how to have a
relationship with him I gave my heart to
the Lord I asked Jesus into my heart and
when I was young and I love Jesus when I
was young I loved going up to my room
and praying to him I remember going up
because reading my Bible I just loved
seeking Him as a child and then it
wasn't like one day I just said oh you
know what I think I'm gonna turn my back
on all that you know it's a slippery
slope and for me what it really was was
in the high school time I was honestly
just popularity I just wanted to feel
cool and I want for 'inna everything
that comes along with popularity it's
really a very sort of slippery slope
thing at first you know it was just a
token Christian and I wasn't
drinking the beer you know doing the
things at first but little by little of
course you know they start having more
of an effect on me that I was certainly
having on them you know we rationalize a
lot of us like oh you know if I don't
tell them you know nobody else will I'm
the only Christian who can reach that
stuff how we rationalize like our this
is why I'm doing this but really that
started my whole rebellion and on on my
path of that and then you know a little
by little around engaging in activities
that I previously vim so again and and
then shortly after high school a good
friend of mine was killed in a drunk
driving accident a motorcycle accident
and it just threw my world upside down
because now I had to face okay what do I
leave where where is she and do I
believe in heaven and hell or don't I
and it just it just completely threw my
world upside down and so I just prayed
for a few days like what is truce
I mean and you know just show me what
truth is my good friend this is a
rebellious heart and I saw this
overwhelming feeling to call a relative
of mine who at the time I didn't know at
all really short of like a couple you
know home calls here and there for happy
birthday throughout the years but um I
didn't really know this person so it
really struck me as odd to call them but
the so persistent the finally I called
and I was just kind of weird I was just
like I don't really know why I'm calling
you my friend just died and I just want
to know where they are and what I didn't
know is that my relative was a medium
and psychic and Wow and they asked me
one sweetie you know your friend wants
you to know well ask me what her name
was told him her name and that your
friend wants you to know that she's okay
and that she's here with me right now is
there anything you want to ask her no
wow like what an amazing opportunity and
the moment that happened
this is the best I can explain it thinks
with energy and the spiritual realm are
so hard to explain in words but the best
way I can explain what happened when she
started talking to me when she said your
friend is here with me now um is this
like physical energy that felt like just
like love and peace and euphoria and
just shot through the bottom of my feet
and just like up through my body in
these waves like this this wave of like
this physical euphoric peaceful felt
like peace felt like love and I thought
I know God is love and this feels like
love I've been praying for answers so
this has to be God right like that was
my that was my colleagues tasklist
feels like love I know about in love it
has to be God never mind that the Bible
warns strictly throughout the entire
Bible warrants to stay away from
communicating with the spiritual realm
not to seek spiritus not to go there not
to go to medium sorcery all of this
stuff it's strictly warns against and I
knew that in my mind but at the time I
just thought well that must just be
because it's not really the Bible things
that's not really real like clearly you
know I had a choice to make
I haven't choice to either believe what
I was feeling or what I knew the Bible
says and at that time I chose to choose
my feelings over the Word of God and
that is really what completely said it
sent me on my on my path in the New Age
and towards spiritualism you know
throughout that conversation I did end
up having conversation with my relative
who was channeling this energy who I
thought was my friend who just passed
away me she answered questions about how
she died then she would have had no way
of knowing but she gave me details and I
was like it was has to be true but the
Bible tells us that those things
another thing that they're not realistic
they're very real and the reason why the
Lord wants us to stay away from
because they're very deceptive um and
that's it just need me a hook line and
sinker because it felt like it felt like
love I was getting all these details and
and so and I got all these details too
about the things that were contradictory
to the Bible things about past past lies
and her next life and why she had to go
at the time she did all sorts of things
that were country don't know one would
have God but basic tweet that yes nature
at the end of that conversation I wanted
to learn I could help people the way
that my relative had helped me and my
route if there was nothing malicious and
I wrote it either they they just really
truly thought that they were helping and
they have the sweetest heart right they
don't they analyze yeah they don't
realize that they're in and part of a
deception as well I mean think and think
of this like the it's so amazing to me
no matter how many times I hear this it
always kind of centers around emotional
experiences like like where all of a
sudden you have this this this choice to
make emotions versus the truth and it's
like when you're dealing with a loved
one a family member or whatever you can
see how many people are just like all of
my logic is telling me this but all of
my feelings are telling me this I'm
gonna go with this I mean that's that's
just a common thing that people are
gonna do and I think that's that's what
feeds into the deception so easily but I
find it also so ironic that the first
thing that they want to do is contradict
their things of the Bible you know it's
like they first you know start kind of
communicating with you or telling you
things that are just like wait wait that
doesn't really line up and it's like
that seems to be the end goal of their
that they're changing the words of God
since we do a lot with media influence I
see this what you're talking about all
over mainstream television now I mean
like there's reality shows of a teenage
medium
want more Monica I just got chills and
next Tuesday see it and believe it did
you lose your mom did you whisper in her
ear at the time of her passing because
she says I heard you and I know
everything that you said to me all new
Monica the medium
next Tuesday 8/7 central ABC Family ABC
Family and I have a mother-in-law who
she knows to stay away from that stuff
but at the same time she'll watch it and
be crying tears of joy for these people
and her husband's like stop watching
this junk you know it's you know it's
the deception she's like I know it's
like it can even pull you in when you
know the truth because of the emotion
that's wrapped up in it what was the
name of that TV show that that the
little boy had died and he came back
like 30 years later yeah there was a
resurrection it was a resurrection did
your son go missing sir right I haven't
he's okay my son died 32 years ago well
they're well turning green and goes
million miles per hour frog in a blender
honey where is it
[Music]
there was on ABC yeah there was an ABC
television show that they did that and I
remember when I watched the trailer the
moment that his parents realize they're
talking to their son that would died 30
years ago it was like all of a sudden
all the hair went up on the back of my
neck you know and I was just like it
gave me a physical feeling just watching
the trailer to it that trailer what's
really fascinating about it is it really
pitted science against religion right
because when you're watching it he goes
this little boy who's supposed to have
been dead he goes to the priest and the
priest you know he's like did I die and
the priest is like and another cliff
he's like I don't know why he's here I
don't know what this is supposed to mean
when they're talking about the science
they're saying you know we've done his
DNA test it matches this is your son so
it's like your science has the answers
religion doesn't have the answers but
here you have something physically in
front of your eyes how could your eyes
be lying to you just like your
experience Jessica how could these
details be lying to you so important
that we what we watch what fakeness so
sneaky he uses the same tricks he's been
using it since the garden you know did
God really say that you know time didn't
really say that and the thing that
really struck me about even the garden
is that she saw that the fruit was good
the Bible tells us like God told her
this is gonna leave definitely not God
told her like this isn't good for you
like don't go there and she she saw that
it was good so Satan packages things and
presents them as whether or not and
that's why it's so important that we run
everything from our TV shows do the
choices that we make in our exercise to
how we seek Him you know there's all
sorts of garbage out there and lies out
there about meditation and that's the
whole other can of worms that we can get
into later if you might want to you but
you know all of these things like where
Satan takes what God intends for good
often times or he says today we
whatever it is God is very clear about
these things and so we've got to say
like okay my doctor told me to you know
do yoga class or to do this relaxation
meditation or you know if this is just a
gym so it's harmless right like no
because I say your gym does not mean it
it's harmless just because your doctor
told you to do it the talk show host or
whoever not mean aren't listen you've
got to run you things through the filter
of the Word of God is giving us the
answers to all of these things you know
he tells us that his word is living and
active and it doesn't complete work and
we can take all of these questions that
we have and we can run it through the
Bible and look to the answers and God's
very clear about all these that's right
and I think if you're if you're actually
putting that in God's hands saying God
show me the truth like like hey I'm
confused by this you know direct to me
direct my past that's why the Bible says
God will direct your path to the right
or to the left he will he will show you
if there is error here and you're asking
God show me the error then either it's
going to contradict something he says
God will not ignore you in this in this
situation but one thing that's also
really important to remember it's just
like I was asking God what is truth when
we get these answers let's make sure
they really are from God because again
it's so easy like I've been asking God
and then I had this conversation with
this person right afterwards and they
told me about this yoga class so they
told me about these tarot readings or
they told me about it though this has to
be from God right like something seems
like an answer does not mean end of the
answer if it doesn't line up completely
with the Word of God not your
rationalized version of oh maybe the
Bible really meant this the Bible didn't
really mean what you're trying to make
it mean it means what it says I think
that's really important
seek the Lord to remember that's right
basically exactly what it says in
Deuteronomy 13 that's exactly the
principle because God says I don't care
even if you know if it's a prophet or a
dreamer of dreams and it comes true
he says even if it becomes true if
they're saying something that leads you
away from me and that's the end result
you don't have anything to do with it
even if they what they said was true
he's like it it could because it's a
test to see whether you love me and
you'll keep my Commandments
and God does not contradict himself so
if if you're seeking for answers
something's given to you and it's
different than the Word of God that's
why that filter is always I mean that's
that that's the main point we try to
hammer on this show you got a judge
everything through the Word of God I
mean doesn't matter what piece of media
music video games you name it whatever
thing you're into in life if it is going
against the Word of God there's a
problem with it
yeah Satan is a master deceiver he's
looking for that opportunities like oh
wait they're praying for something I got
an answer for them you know and if they
don't know the word then they're gonna
take it such a huge New Age taking over
right now because people don't know the
Word of God and you know the Bible tells
us that Satan is he prowls around like a
lion looking for who he can devour and
he's doing it all over through this
through the new age in this fascination
with a new age because it looks like
light in like everybody wants to feel
special everybody wants to feel like you
I'm having this esoteric spiritual
experience and again back to the
feelings right it makes them feel
special and that's just one way baby
yeah so so you got involved in this sort
of scene behind the veil or or you know
your your your Christian walk takes a
different turn tell us a little bit
about that yeah so I really a whole new
age section of the bookstore if you will
just like opened up before me all these
things that were previously forbidden to
me that I never would have even thought
about I now viewed as truce like Oh God
must he
in this direction so I just you know
opened up the doors to all of these
things and um it's not very relative for
instructions like I want to be able to
do this too and I was told I'm relative
and append from you know many other
different paths that I would end up
taking from foodism to you know just
new-age seeking spirits and working with
different angels and spirits some spirit
guides and light masters and everything
and um before I go on with that a lot of
people who are into spiritualism right
now might be thinking oh okay this just
happened with Jessica because she didn't
put up for protection probably she must
have just had a negative experience
because you didn't put up her protection
one thing I want made clear from the
beginning is that I have always thought
I was dealing in love and light and I
was taught properly properly um to to
always put that protection I thought
there were dark energy and light
energies and I always only dealt from my
perspective and light so there is no
difference between the light side and
the dark side and there's either the
Lord side and they're safe inside and if
it doesn't line up with Scripture it is
all demonic that's right period it
doesn't matter if it's called even even
the name Jesus it's like people use that
like in the New Age Jesus is thrown
around and like oh I'm working with you
know this ascended master or this being
of light or you know Jesus there are
other spirits who can take that name to
and and amass the things that they're
not but yeah all that to say that just
projected me on the path I learned that
um if I wanted to learn to communicate
with the spiritual realm the first thing
that I needed to do was to start
meditation practice meditation was the
key to opening oneself as a receiver of
the spiritual realm which is really
important you guys because this
mindfulness meditation movement that is
all throughout schools probably in your
and she's part of a growing movement of
nonprofits and foundations whose mission
is to bring meditation into public
schools with your eyes closed breathe in
through your nose calm classroom is a
research-based social-emotional learning
program that's composed of two-minute
breathing stretching relaxation and
focusing techniques every day here at
Robert Coleman elementary school begins
with what the school calls a mindful
moment it's a 15-minute blend of yoga
and meditation and you can actually see
some of it going on behind me right now
in this first grade classroom all right
how do I do it
we have shape we do your nose
[Music]
at Spring Hill Elementary all is quiet
in Allison Bowers third-grade class
earlier this school year Luisa Alva soo
a certified mindfulness meditation
teacher came to Bauer's classroom to
teach students how to incorporate
mindfulness tools and practices into
their everyday lives
one breath through your nose feel like
all the way through your body on any
given day at any given time at the salt
elementary nestled in Colorado's Roaring
Fork Valley two more big breaths on your
own you can find students taking a brain
break
it's a cornerstone of mind up a program
dedicated to bringing mindfulness into
the classroom they just made a Barbie
ball that that is mindful meditation
like a whole Barbie doll and if you
actually go to the Barbie website for
the doll she teaches you how to do
mindful meditation sits there and does
the whole thing you play you you sit
here like this you open up your mind you
if you let the thoughts pass by in
clouds we just did a whole video on this
and it's like oh my goodness all these
children that are gonna play with this
doll I mean they sell the doll in the
pose of a meditating Barbie it's wild
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow insane and this like that doesn't
even surprise me it like makes me want
to throw up but it doesn't surprise me
because that's just that with the
movement of this met mindfulness
meditation it's in it's in schools all
over the country like most schools have
it being pushed in the classrooms and
parents don't even know about it they're
not even told about it and that's not
called mindfulness meditation it's
packaged in all of these fun little
programs like call go noodle and I mean
I couldn't even possibly begin to call
all of them out there's so many of them
and that's actually one that I found
that somebody had written me into he
heard of it you know I have a check in
my heart about this so I looked into it
like okay something's not quite right
but you know it's all like oh get up out
of your seat and move around and play
and like who doesn't want their kid to
do that there's nothing wrong with that
and I had to sign up and like create an
account so that I could see what else
they were teaching and sure enough if I
keep scrolling keep scrolling through
all their little programs looks like on
us of things that's right looks like fun
nothing can be wrong with it so the
point we're like you're starting to
think gosh I might just be stupid for
thinking anything about this and then
BAM
there it is oh here's your little
relaxation exercise just notice your
breath just focus on your breath take a
deep breath in ha here's your relaxation
exercise like no that is okay I'm gonna
tell you why got the a you guys know why
this is so dangerous thank you a lot of
you it's it's like the deception to to
prayer and communication with God this
is literally if you're if prayer is
opening up you up to literally
conversation to the throne room of God
then meditation is opening you up to the
literally pits of hell and you're
communicating with the spirits you know
what I mean
that is good but and if anybody's
interested in this I've done an
exhaustive research study on this on my
website where I lift up in the
concordance I'm the strongest
concordance and look of every single
time meditate is in the Bible and it's
listed there on my website under
meditation if you're interested I highly
recommend that you go there because it
shows the context of this scripture so
that you can see what the Lord means by
it shows the original Greek and Hebrew
and the definition is always every
single time it means that thoughtful
focus thought on the Word of God this is
what brings us closer it's thinking
about now Satan takes that and he twists
it and isn't that confusing he uses the
exact same word meditate and does the
exact opposite don't think about it he
says just focus on your breath now that
just yeah I'm so harmless you may be
thinking like nothing was wrong with
sitting and relaxing and focusing on
your breath like I completely disagree
with that having gone through the entire
process of it because this is a path and
paths take you somewhere and this is a
demonic pact this is the beginning steps
you're not supposed to just stay there
and you're not going to if you keep up
with this practice it will the very
first thing that there's I mean at first
it's just frustrating for a lot of us to
begin and that's just normal it's just
like oh I'm not getting anything out of
this like I can't my thoughts are all
over the place but the more you practice
practice practice just let go of your
thoughts just let go of your thoughts
return your focus to your breath or your
sacred word or whatever it is your your
there's a lot of Christians apps out
there right now that are just completely
non Christian meditation that are let's
be careful guys there's a lot of apps
out there and these churches out there
that are giving instruction and demonic
the beginning path of demonic meditation
and it seems like like because they'll
even give you like Oh take a scripture
and or a word like faith and just
about it over and over and over and just
relax or say it over and over and over
if there's any time you hear anything
like like say it over and over or think
it doesn't matter what petitioners what
the Bible refers to it as vain
repetitions exactly it's vain
repetitions and it's very dangerous so
the first thing that's gonna start
happening if you continue on this path
is you're gonna start feeling feelings
of peace like oh okay
well before this is always been
frustrating but I kept up and you know
what I do feel a little bit well and
relaxed at the end of that number it's
part and then you're gonna keep doing it
and keep doing it and then oh I'm
getting deeper relax like I think I'm
starting to feel like more clarity and
balance in my life lie or not is gonna
open up a whole other can of worms in
this practice is opening you up to the
demonic realm and it's gonna start
creating havoc and other places in your
life that you have you're not gonna make
the connection but it's coming from this
but then it's gonna start deepening into
esoteric experience this where like oh I
heard this third eye opening I like had
this esoteric experience where I when I
was in meditation today I I heard this
finger I smelled this thing right saw
this thing up here in my forehead and or
I you know I heard this thing coming out
whatever it was it's gonna be something
that feels special and like wow this is
awesome and it made me feel so peaceful
and and loving and that's what he does
and it's gonna get deeper and deeper and
deeper until it starts slippery slope
into deeper esoteric experiences and
guess what these are all demonic
manipulations and yeah that's basically
it all this mindfulness stuff is being
taught and you're in public schools
without parents you
being told about there was actually a
book that just came out by candy Gunther
gram she's this professor of religious
studies at Indiana University and she
did her undergrad master's doctor at a
Harvard like super super intelligent
lady who's dedicated a mass amount of
her life to studying this stuff and she
just did published this academic work
with just like sick staff of research
about how mindfulness meditation and
yoga is being packaged as something it's
not and being it presented and like
there is a there is a like conscious
movement to make it appear scientific
and make it appear non spiritual and
there is a movement of people who are
working on this to get it into the
school and they're doing it and it all
across the nation but yeah that book
it's called debating yoga and
mindfulness in public schools super
interesting Wow
cool maybe we'll put a little link for
that in the description you can just see
them like you know so funny like in
school they won't that you have prayer
but they'll totally like to have all
this other leg of meditation nonsense
you know and it's like I heard you
mention like you're gonna continue with
this because at first it feels like
nothing's happening but then you feel
something so it kind of becomes like an
addiction but then you said something
about like these things will start to
happen in your life that are kind of
chaotic which only pushes you to go
deeper right because you're like oh I'm
getting more stress or whatever what I
need now you're starting to rub crystals
and the feng shui and all this stuff
right your life where you know things if
there can be periods of your life where
you'll make it seem like oh as a result
of this practice like everything going
well like Oh ever since I started this I
feel like so much more loving like I'm
so much more balanced finds so much more
thoughtful of others I'm so much more
blah blah blah blah blah and
you know it whatever the period of time
is like something will start to happen
and it I don't you know it's different
for every hey it could be your marriage
starts to fall apart
or you're getting some sort of sickness
or you're getting anxiety now or like
higher stress these things happen to
worker or whatever and exactly what
you're saying you're gonna run to like
this practice that makes you feel peace
and that's just one of the many ways
that it separates people from God
because what does God want us to do he
wants us to run to him and that's what
grows our relationship with him right
that that relationship is where we run
to him when we have a problem and and
not ourselves and we go to scripture to
seek the answers to our problems not to
seeking to tap back into this meditative
state where we're gonna feel peace what
feels like peace
so what was it for you that's what I was
gonna say sounds like a personal
experience here yeah yeah what made you
run deeper into it really what motivated
me to run deeper into it was just the
validation of my esoteric experiences
that I continue to have that's what
validated it to me it's the deeper I
went the more esoteric experiences I had
and I was like wow like I must be on my
path of truth and I wanted to learn how
I could and I want to keep going deeper
on that path so that I could then get
enough tools in my tool belt so to speak
to help other people reach this truth
that I felt like I had found so you know
I lived in a Buddhist Center in Berkeley
I lived in the ashram and India did my
yoga teacher training over there in
India I wanted to get to the root of
what yoga really was because I thought
Yoga adds like wow what a great tool in
my tool belt so to speak to reach people
who would otherwise be close to these
meditative practices like Christian you
know
and it wasn't malicious it was kind of a
mentality like now I just look back and
shake my head at myself so many ways but
at the time it was like I want to help
them even though they don't know they
need to be helped kind of thing you know
like this will bring them more peace
they're just closed off because they
don't know but here if I can you know
get them in it's at a gym class so here
if I can just get them to a yoga class
and I can start introducing this
meditation to them and that's what yoga
does so we have a DVD that we're gonna
send you in the mail
you can watch this whole project where
we actually followed a guy around who
spent thirty some odd years in martial
arts and I mean got really caught up in
the whole thing and this this touches on
the yoga aspect too but what's really
interesting is when you when you see
where the roots of all this stuff come
from then it's all of a sudden you you
you pick your head up out and you look
at what's happening in the Christian
Church and it's like you go oh my
goodness like like this is just like
getting its tentacles in the Christian
faith and then pulling people out of
that I mean he left the faith and
everything else like this so we'll send
you this for those of you that are
watching you guys want to know a little
bit more about the esoteric roots of
yoga and martial arts and stuff like
this we got this video on our website
you guys can click the link below and
get a hold of that but but yeah I mean
yoga is seems like that non-threatening
I'm just doing it for the action of it
the strategy yeah that's what everybody
says right I'm just stretching you
cannot just do the stretching and I'll
tell you what it might film crazy to
some of you like well if I want it to be
non spiritual it's not spiritual right
wrong and doesn't work that way in the
spiritual realm and um there's this
quote by candy on the ground again she's
studied this extensively and published
in it was Christianity today a number of
years ago she she talked about this and
she said um she said you know Christians
in particular tend to think that if
something is non spiritual but it's not
spiritual she says that they don't
thirst that over time their intent
actually changes to spiritual and and
you don't have any control over that and
there's so listen okay here's look
here's a great way to explain it I'm
gonna quote this this guru because
people who know what yoga actually is
they know this my gurus they know that
yes when you ask a guru they'll tell you
you what you can't separate it you can't
call it Christian yoga if that's a joke
to them
I mean you can't you can't call it that
because it doesn't it doesn't
it's like saying Christian seance like
ya know we'll be honest anyway there's a
lot in the West who are like
purposefully packaging innocent man it's
not but most gurus like people who know
the reality of this who are going to be
honest will tell you like you cannot
separate the spiritual out I am this
quote by man juju ease it's his name and
his dad was um basically like majorly
responsible for bringing the West yoga
and like help introduced like the type
of yoga that had at gyms all over the
place and listen to this quote by him
because it is so so telling
he says hits Milan is he referring to
his dad is that yoga would take you
automatically to the meditative state
you see that's how it will draw you into
the spiritual path see that's why he
says was another part the yoga asanas
the poses are important you just do it
don't talk about philosophy
99% practice 1% philosophy that's what
he taught listen to the star guide you
just keep doing it keep doing it keep
doing it then slowly it talking about a
spiritual will start opening up inside
of you so he's saying then you just keep
doing the poses alone
don't talk about any of the other stuff
you don't have to talk about it your
intentions irrelevant your knowledge of
what is going on on a spiritual level is
completely irrelevant I was taught that
across varying traditions like it
doesn't matter if you understand what
you're doing the act is the invocation
the poses it within a yoga class are the
invocation and that activates the
spiritual realm and what people don't
understand is that they don't have any
control over that it's like the best way
I can explain it it's like um you guys
are familiar with a Ouija board oh yeah
I mean never played with one but I know
what it is
it's like seemingly harmless board game
introducing Hasbro's Ouija family
concentrate here and I'm not moving in
isn't that what Satan guys they like
packages that have this fun game so with
a point where we Christians who seek
truth are supposed to like maybe feeling
like oh and I just am I just being
overly zealous like this is getti Mike
sold at like Walmart we're out of
ivanova sold at Walmart now but I'm
assuming it's obvious yeah it sold all
over the place but those of us you know
the reality of what it is know that it
is a spiritual tool so it's a board that
has letters all over it right there's a
plastic game piece and the practitioner
or the game player puts their hand on
the little game piece and that act is
the invitation now if you've ever played
the Ouija board like some of you may
have played it and like nothing happened
but sometimes
when you place your hands there that
little thing is gonna take off shooting
around spelling out words and you don't
have any control over that because your
act is the invocation you can think this
is stupid there's nothing spiritual
about this this is just a harmless game
it doesn't matter what you think you put
your fingers there and that opened up
you up to the spiritual realm and
activated it
now one point I want to make about that
really quickly is that there's nothing
wrong with the letters on the Ouija
board right like those letters it's what
the Bible's right side like why but
there's nothing wrong with the letters
just like there's nothing wrong with
stretches like Satan doesn't get to
claim letters and he doesn't get to
claim stretches it's the context within
which we use them don't use letters
within the context of the litchi board
don't eat a stretches within the context
of a yoga class because it is the whole
purpose of yoga is to yoga means to yoke
or to unite and we're often told in our
culture
well that means to you yoke together
your mind and your body and your spirit
because doesn't that sound lovely like
they found a sugar-coated way to get it
to us it's to yoke with to open to and
yoke with the spiritual realm and
becoming a receiver to open oneself as a
receiver to the spiritual world now
those of us who believe in the Bible who
trust in the word of God
know that everything spiritual is not
good and I think that's a huge
misconception now guys - it's been like
with all this influx of new age and TV
shows and everything we're being taught
like oh if it's spiritual and let's be
good no one is not like it either it's
either again line up with Scripture
right and that's that's where like when
you see major celebrities Oprah Winfrey
you know constantly putting out there
this spiritualize idea without really
saying listen there's there's the Bible
truth and then there's this other
spiritual world on the other side it's
like you know she was doing breathing
exercises on national television
I mean with millions of people watching
and doing the action I think you mean
she said you know hey breathe like this
and like Eckhart Tolle and all those
guys are just like ah it's it's out in
the public and yeah you're right it's
like doing yoga is is and saying that
it's like nothing more than stretches is
like literally plane with a Ouija board
and saying I'm gonna do a spelling game
right you know to me it's like everyone
would laugh at you and be like that's
not what that board is for go ahead
Mikey I was saying when you mentioned
the poses have a meaning to it and made
me think of like Shadrach Meshach in a
minute ago all they had to do was simply
bow their bodies before an image and
they could have had their lives
preserved but they said no we're not
gonna do that because that's giving my
allegiance to demons basically they
could have bent down and tied their shoe
yeah so correct me if I'm wrong Jessica
but it seems like I remember that these
poses are often worship stances to Hindu
gods is that right it's movement
meditation worship to specific deities
each like different poses our invocation
and I mean implication means inviting
and worship of specific deities in which
they represent yes you are correct which
is again a very strong reason why you
would not participate in such a thing
right yeah and again it doesn't matter
if you if your intent is there or not
your enjoyment again is irrelevant and
activating spiritual realm there is an
interesting study just done a few years
ago by the Journal of health psychology
so this is like a completely secular
studies nothing to do with Christian
anything just a secular study and they
wanted to look at why people start yoga
and why they keep doing it and they
found that most people start Yoga for
exercise purposes right like that how
would you
most of my months people started but
over time over 62% of practitioners and
ferrous students and 85% of teachers
over time changed the reason why they
did yoga spiritual purpose so that's
really really telling why because we
don't find that with running right right
like anything that's not spiritual to
the core right you don't start anything
and then keep doing it for spiritual
reasons except yoga because it is
spiritual in the study is say like it's
telling us exactly what we've been
saying it activates the spiritual realm
and in the past and it takes you
somewhere it's taking you further away
from the Lord and that is the goal and
that is what it's doing people don't
know too that why do people don't know
that there's a Yoga Sutras there's a
text I wouldn't call it doctrine but not
for means truth so I'm not gonna call it
that it said it's like an ancient texts
that tell us exactly what yoga is and
you know what it reads that guy in the
how-to book for sorcery over and over
like the first thing is that you know
this lays the groundwork for
communicating with spirits this lays the
groundwork for it that's like and I
don't get too much into it because the
Bible warns us in many places like
Deuteronomy 12:30 roman 1619 not to get
super and snared by blue chinks like
don't get super fascinated with demonic
and pagan teachings because they're
meant to be a trap right there's a lot
of flowery stuff from the Yoga Sutras
that again it's like oh yeah like of
course that sounds nice that sounds
lovely that's peaceful who wouldn't want
that and then BAM here's these sneaky
little oh and by the way you can also
communicate with spirits it's also going
to open you to this nice pen those
things that if you're interested in that
on my website too
I have Yoga Sutras listed under yoga
yoga section and I show just enough you
know just Yoga Sutras you Yoga scripture
final scripture Yoga scripture bible
scripture antithetical antithetical
completely they completely contradict
one another over and over and over again
and again for those who are saying like
oh well I don't do that part yes you do
like you can't separate it out and
there's one other important thing to
consider with yoga too right actually
before I say that there's one other
thing I just want to say like a couple
of scriptures that I think are really
important and that too it's like the
Lord all throughout the Old Testament
Anthony doesn't memo he tells us to come
out and be separate you know as you said
in Deuteronomy here's a couple that I
just really like find fascinating you
said break down their altars smash their
sacred stones and burn their astral
poles in the fire when when the
Israelites are going in when he's
sending them into these new places he
said you must not worship the Lord your
God in their way in Deuteronomy 12
that's three to four he said you know
cut nail their idols don't have anything
to do with them he says just a little
bit later in 12:30 he says be careful
not to become ensnared by inquiring
about their God's sakes how did these
nations serve their gods yeah we will
need to see the same and again II think
you must not worship the Lord your God
in there wait that's it two times like
right after another don't do it in their
way he doesn't say you know what that
one has some redeeming quality if you
know what just plug me into that one
because the stretching is gonna help
your back on that way right right right
so earlier you were saying that you know
the when you're dabbling with this stuff
is gonna cause bad things to happen in
your life it's not like you were
speaking from experience did did
something like that happen to you that
kind of draws you in more yeah yeah so
like I mentioned like the
experiences what really drew me in more
to you know get deeper and deeper in my
practices because I thought it was
London life but also you know that's
where I would go hurt you know it's my
life
piece you know if things were getting as
time went on I just I had a really
tumultuous relationship with an
ex-boyfriend now ex-boyfriend of mine um
that really just was super unhealthy and
and I would've never guessed like my
reactions that I was having and I was
just starting to get really depressed I
never experienced depression at all
before sort of when I used to like party
and drink a lot like when I drank every
day for months great like got a little
bit depressive and stopped everything
and then what do you know actually make
you depressed but other than that you
know I've never experienced like any
depression outside of that or anything
and I never in a million years would
have made that connection um yeah it was
threatening to get pretty serious but
before I didn't like share that with
anybody um but basically um I was in
this tumultuous relationship and instead
of getting out of it I for some reason
kept me kept getting deeper in our
relationship and then we're moving in
together and then we're doing that um
and so my mom just said it was but uh
she knew that was tumultuous and she
just like you know why don't you guys
just go get some counseling and get some
tools to help you communicate better I
thought okay well that sounds like
what's probably a good idea and she's
like I you know I have some friends who
are counselors and I knew they were
Christian counselors and I was like ya
know not thrown out anything to do with
that so you're already like no more
Christian you were already like against
Christianity then yes
yeah I yeah I had grown to I went from
the little girl who loved Jesus do you
know on this path grown to think
Christians were just the stupid most
ignorant people with really bad taste
and music
when should I love you now Christian I
was probably just you know my own
rebellious heart didn't want to hear
Jesus a phrase but you know that was my
view of Christians any I didn't have
anything to do with anybody Christian I
had such hardness in my heart for Jesus
and just view them as just hypocrites
and didn't have anything to do with
Jesus being preached to down my throat
or anything and so she finally convinced
me that you know yes they're Christians
but they also are counselors they're
fully capable of giving you
communicative tools for your
relationship without shoving Jesus down
your throat and so so we finally went
and they have this beautiful ranch out
here and in Oregon and my boyfriend at
the time and I went up there and he
spent the first day up there then I came
up and while I was there
the Lord was just really doing a work on
my heart and there had been other things
to make a long story short there invent
some other things that in retrospect I
can see that that Jesus had been working
on my heart and other ways too to just
kind of chip away at some of that
hardness um and I completely attributed
that to my faithful mom just never
stopping praying for me so I know if you
are a parent or you have a friend who if
you know somebody who is in this stuff
don't stop praying for the you guys
because I was most hardened person could
possibly be I was just and and if the
work didn't get a hold of me and opened
my eyes being get a hold of your child
he'd get over your friend or whoever it
is just keep praying my mom was diligent
and prayed constantly for years and year
years and I am so thankful that she did
I have the same story
yeah yeah beautiful so yeah well I was
there at the ranch the Lord really did a
work on my heart and I just started
thinking over dinner they were they were
sharing just some different ways that
they'd help people in their ministries
they weren't preaching to me at all I
think the Lord really gave them
discernment they were just sharing like
ways that they'd helped people in their
ministry in Alaska and just become free
of stuff that they've been dealing with
addiction just different things that I
just started thinking wow like here are
some people who are so misguided but at
the time I was thinking here are some
people who are working with Jesus the
same way I'm working with you know my
healing energies like Buddha and Tara
and these Angels of Light and my Reiki
energy every is another thing you know I
just thought that's awesome like here
they are working with Jesus to help
bring people freedom and it really just
like broke something some hardness and
me like Oh like why am I not working
with Jesus you know I just thought Jesus
is really that foundational relationship
I had when I was a child I loved and I
prayed to him he we're all growing up
and I just thought all these other
energies yeah I've worked with this one
for a little bit and then this wood for
a little bit I view them like these are
more acquaintance energies why am I not
working with Jesus in my healing work
would I know that from you know I know
that he was a master healer why am I not
working with him and I didn't again
completely misguided but thank you Lord
for taking yes any shred of opening um
so I I got down on my knees that night
when I was by myself and at that time I
still viewed all the other spirits and
energies that I was working with and
good
just said to them you know thank you for
everything that you taught me which like
is so crazy to me now but no makes the
reality of what they were but I'm on I'm
just gonna be working with Jesus and
then I went to Jesus and I said Jesus
I'm so sorry for the way that I have
treated you using his name like solely
as a swear word and just been so
repulsed by his name and just said you
know if you'll have me back which I knew
he would from my Bible teaching as a
child I knew Jesus always forgave us but
if you'll have me back I just only want
to work with you from now on
and I had no idea but I had an emotion
on a spiritual level with that we're
good I thought that Jesus was just
another ascended master like all rest of
them I thought they were all working
together Jesus was the same I'm not
making before I've done that all that
stuff you know all the time we're like I
know I've been working with this angel
but you know what now I'm gonna work
with this this spirit this energy and I
never had any problem with like yeah
they're like fine work with that angel
yeah go for it he's just my buddy
seamless transition Jesus gone yeah
it wouldn't be till a month later til I
would find the reality of that prayer
well that prayer had put into motion and
so the next morning I you know went
downstairs and and told this amazing
couple Donald and Dawn and said you know
I decided I'm gonna start working with
Jesus now and I just want to follow his
path and I'm not like regular Christian
or anything I said I don't want to
really I don't want to like be churchy
or anything like that like I just want
to know what Jesus said I didn't want
anybody else's opinion I just want to
know what Jesus said they want to follow
him and they again I think the Lord just
gave them so much discretion and like
and responding to me and they were like
well but you know what we would
recommend that you do is if you're
serious about this is you know don't do
any of your other stuff don't do your
yoga or meditation or any of your other
you know stuff that you're doing and
just say I'm just going to UM you know
pursue Jesus's ass that's it um they
said we recommend that you read a
chapter a day in Luke and a chapter in
Proverbs and and you know and friend
read it out loud and pray every day do
this like every single day and so I did
and I soon I cut out proverbs and I was
doing like bare minimum and reading a
chapter in Luke a day and and pray every
day and my boy ever another time work
and I were both dangerous and and to
make a long story short a very long
story short all in all in the foot of
effort type purposes they just can't get
into all of it right now but uh
basically um I think the timing of this
is really really fascinating guys
because I had this hardness in my heart
even praying out loud like saying
Jesus's name just like I just had this
like Lula like this is cringe about it
and I was just like Jesus please take
that away I don't want that being a
reaction to you and so I've been praying
that and toward the end of Luke as you
guys know it's the you know that's the
gospel it's the life of Jesus and for
the end of your life of Jesus he in the
garden and he knows what's gonna happen
he knows he's going to be crucified
any there and he's praying to God and
and you can just like it when you're
reading it when I when I was reading it
I just like reddit in a new I knew this
story but it just hit me differently it
was like Jesus's friend God if there's
any other way take this from me please
like he knew what he was gonna have to
experience me said not my will but your
will be done and I was like that just
hit me
like he he went through that for me and
and it just broke me anew and just hit
me in a new level and I just started
crying and it surprised me my are my
reaction was surprised me and then the
next day I read of course the
crucifixion all right read the
crucifixion and then the next day I read
the resurrection of course um and again
with the crucifixion like same thing it
just it it just broke me and uh and then
the following day was I read the
resurrection and I think this is
important because the very next day
after I read the resurrection and like
Angie it conquers sin and and like
accomplish the work that he set out to
do and saving us and uh and the very
next day I was after an argument with my
boyfriend at the time um I was sitting
at the table and out of nowhere nowhere
this what felt like the best way I can
explain it is it felt like evil and hate
and everything just like have you ever
had a nightmare where you like just you
just wake up and chew your terror like
that's the best way I can explain it
like that feeling combined with if you
ever walk into a place it's like just
super super creepy and you're like dude
I got to get out of here there's just
something creepy in here so it was like
those feelings like mashed into a ball
combined with like eagle and hate and
tear and just like turn up the intensity
as far as it'll go like in this ball
only instead of being on the outside it
was deep within the pit of my stomach
and it felt like it was like rising
rising rising up and it just like hit me
like like it's like out of nowhere and
all of us unlike tears sort of flowing
down my face I was at my boyfriend at
the time and I was like I have no idea
what's happening right now we just start
praying I knew it was spiritual yeah and
he held my hand and just great and I I
don't even know where it hang up our
body's been cracking
the name of Jesus like you have to say
Jesus and he is praying to God and uh I
guess like again of course there's
nothing wrong with praying to God but at
that time like meat there's power and
the name of training and it's right
complex work and we had to make very
clear like who we were calling on like
it's what God are you afraid to we're
praying of Jesus of the Bible like Jesus
the Father the time the Holy Spirit like
this is who we are praying to and it
felt like that prayer was like felt
every time like the word Jesus was great
and just felt like a life preserver it
felt like it's the hardest thing to
explain in words again like these
esoteric experiences are hard to explain
with words but it felt like this wanted
to consume these ladies and and like the
prayer of Jesus is the only thing
keeping me afloat
and while this is like trying to like
consume me it's the best I can explain
it and and then like again the best I
can explain it is not like I had to like
throw up o me on an energetic level and
I done and not work with the spiritual
realm to know exactly what was happening
was spiritual it was energy coming up
and out of me and it was dark end and
actually so my teeth like out of no fair
just like it started coming up and like
my teeth just like this light like
they're like open and this like deep
throaty like just this subtle deep
throaty like this like I can't even do
it now just like this thing flips and I
was like I get like sheer terror and in
an instant I would like oh my gosh like
it all just click and an instant it was
like the Bible it's true
like everything the Bible says is true
that Satan masquerades as an angel of
light flashed my head and I was like oh
my gosh
I knew exactly what was coming up and
out of me was demonic energies demonic
you
demon mask as all of the energies of
light that I had been working with again
I did enough work in the spiritual realm
to know what was happening on an
energetic level and it was the most
terrifying I don't even have words for
how terrifying that was because I knew
how much I had worked with and how much
I had done and and like the reality that
all of that was demonic was staggering
and the best thing that I had the best
idea that I can explain is it just felt
like another one like you know like the
difference between throwing up when you
like rope and then you feel better and
like poisoning throwing up and I like
just keeps coming it was like it would
like food poisoning for you it was like
a physical throwing up this is all like
there's no like physical like anything
like it was all on an energetic level
and then like same thing as we're
throwing up I you have that like thought
okay I feel like I have to throw up and
I don't care like who's around and it
was like like this is coming out but
there's still that still it's not like
your heartbeat it's not an involuntary
there's still some level of like okay I
am going to do this now and so I had
that like okay this is coming up and out
and like eventually kind of said like
okay and then another one came up and
this time it like their eyeteeth and
like this like not only and like it's
like stronger history now and I felt the
energy so yeah then another with a
circuit coming up and stronger and it
again it like started I get oh it's hard
to know like what to include and what
not to include cuz this it was so
intense
um but basically in a nutshell I'll just
cut to for purposes of like time I
basically I just had this like it was so
strong and so intense it felt like it
was consuming me and I thought that it
might and I terrified me because all I
believed at that moment was what the
Bible says is the only rule book of the
spiritual realm like I thought I had the
rules figured out of the future room I
thought I'd always put up protection I
always was so careful I always was so
diligent to never deal with what I
thought was it
the dark side but here it was unmasked
unveiled all of these things that seems
like light and love like the Lord just
ripped that veil off and let me
experience the reality of what they are
demon every single one of them and so I
just had that splash of just going to
the ranch like I just knew if I could
just go back to the ranch of counselors
friends of my parents who were
Christians I knew they knew the Bible
and so I knew if I could just get there
they would know how to deal with it
because they the Word of God he knew
though the way book if you will they
knew the full book um and so I just had
this um just this thought of like okay
no more it's coming out right now and
then it all just settled back down and
in a matter of moment it was just gone
only I knew it wasn't gone I knew it
settled within me I knew it was still
within me and uh it was serious most
terrifying thing I could ever even ended
up calling Donald and Dawn up at the
ranch and told them what had happened
and they said this doesn't surprise that
really I don't watch scary movies I
don't deal and I thought I didn't feel
in darkness like oh the light like what
the heck yeah and so I asked him if I
could go back up there and they said yes
of course it was like five hours away so
I said get rid of anything that you have
like anything that reminds you of
anything that you don't want to get rid
of it and so I did all that got rid of
everything
um and I mean so much several so much
that anything that had anything to do
with my you know meditation or yoga or
cards or crystals or anything a little
spiritual at all got rid of all of that
and then
I told me to uh I was just terrified if
I can even like drive I thought I didn't
know the rules of the spiritual realm
you really can I even drive there by
myself and I try to run me off a ride no
idea they said you know it's Satan I
knew this was maybe a word for something
but Satan like you thrives on our fear
made he wants us to think you have no
power he wants us to think I'm in
control and uh and that's not the
reality like Jesus is the one who has
the Bible bigger is he who is in grade
Eric's key to it than us and he who is
in the world like Jesus conquers this
Magus told me that you know jump
you let him don't let Satan have one
more ounce of satisfaction don't you let
him have your fear and and so I just
determined told me fight fight worship
music anytime you start feeling fear you
just worship the Lord like worship Jesus
and pray to Him and that's what I did
and and it really just neutralize any
fear like I was determined like I'm not
gonna let Satan have that power over
them anymore he doesn't get to have
right I finally get to the ranch and
part of me was like I don't even want to
like really want to do it but we just
had small pot for a while they asked um
you know what can you give me a name a
name some things that you were working
with and are like name name some things
so I started naming um just naming
certain things that I knew like
different teachers different practices
and then I started just starting off
words again like things that I wasn't
even conscious like fainting on an
energetic level like something just
started like words just started coming
out which I was used to doing you know
weren't used to stuff like that and and
finally we sat down and she said okay
let's I'm cutting out a lot of detail
here for Brooke for purposes of brevity
but um sat down and she said just you
know it wasn't like this big creepy
thing like you would imagine on a movie
she just said
uh not just pray after me
um and pray I prayed prayer after there
was nothing like fantastical or like
amazing you know there's just a prayer
and she's okay now to read this we see
this scripture after me and I repeat the
scripture and um nothing was happening
and again I told myself that whatever
happened I would just let it let it be
like if nothing happened okay Jesus like
I trust you now I don't need to feel
something in order to believe that you
are in control like didn't you say but
these are gone and I don't heal or see
or experience anything like I believe
you give my trust that you're in control
and that is it that you're my go-to now
like not my feelings and on the other
hand I do it myself if something does
happen I'm not going to be afraid like
I'm not going to give Satan that
satisfaction when I'm gonna pray Jesus
his name over and over and not not in
there like the repetition but I'm gonna
say little prayers to him to Jesus um
and and I will not be afraid um I'll
just let whatever the Lord has in this
process like let him control it and uh
and so I did and at that point I was
thinking okay well nothing's gonna
happen I guess I'm not feeling anything
there was none of that like evil hate
tear right and uh and so then dawn said
okay just not gonna say like just take a
deep breath and blow it out and so he
took a deep breath and just believe it
out and then still wasn't feeling
anything wasn't feeling anything and
then toward the end of my breath where I
should have just like should have at the
end of my breath let's take another
breath my stomach started contracting
inward and it just started like
involuntarily like expelling like more
breath like kept going and determine
ended up like subtle rody hits again and
I was like okay the difference was I no
longer felt like I'd been consumed by it
money I thanks that evil like here it
was again it was back like same thing
only it didn't feel like it was
consuming me it was like more this way
authoritative like you are coming up and
out and it wasn't scary like me praying
to Jesus like before my boyfriend at the
time had been afraid and I had it I was
like terrified out of my mind like what
the heck a massive ad not knew what was
happening and I knew that Jesus was in
control and I trusted that and I prayed
to him little prayers and I wasn't
scared I truly was thought and I knew
that everything was going to come up and
out and so I just observed it happening
like the same thing started happening is
that the that my table nights prior
where my teeth bared and this through me
it came out in an energy left and then
one arm came up and out and like bent me
over like like this and I was sitting on
my couch and it was just like it was a
Sun Salutation and and then my body okay
I came back here and then there's like
another teeth bearing throw be hit and
another energy left and and this word
flash we go guys like my arms like
lifted up my experience this energy like
this energy leaving through like my
armpits and then another throaty hit and
explore like teeth bearing rhodius demon
leaving and then said angels like angels
flash to mind and like all day like
Angels of Light I thought I'd worked
with and like a lot like there was
multiple of this happening at one point
like again like I was I had some level
of control of it like I could have
stopped it you know what I mean it
wasn't like oh I have no control of some
of my body as well just happening and it
was like I could have I still had
control
hmm
when to the port at one point and my
body went into it like this child toast
from yoga and my hands came out in front
of me and look my palms like this an
energy like shot through my palms and
then I had another like teeth bearing
rhodius and another energy another
demonic energy leaf and it said Reiki
which is another healing energy healing
energy that we talked about among other
things but I'm in a nutshell like you
just doing that at one point I was like
oh my gosh like how am I gonna go on
these are all gone and and they just
assured me like they will all leave in
the name of Jesus they have to go like
light and dark and also exist like you
are a child of the Lord you have chosen
to follow him you have chosen but your
trust in him and they don't have a
choice
they don't get just nay and so oh and I
think you know I don't think that
anybody you experience this stuff like
this like has to have this experience
right I do I think it can be just as
simple it's like you know every case is
so different I think it can be just as
simple it's like Jesus I did these
things and I'm sorry like if there is
anything with India or outside or inside
or anything like please just remove it
from me I'm a follower of you know I
don't want to have anything to do with
this stuff like simple was that
you know Jesus has control I don't want
anybody to think oh my gosh I've done
these things what do I do
you know I don't how do I get them out I
think the only and this is purely
speculative like I don't know what I
think the Lord allowed me to experience
them coming out like this because I
never in a million years would have ever
ever believed that these things that I
believed were above in life like I never
would have believed no matter who told
me right now that they were actually
darkness right
have you not experienced
and Jesus knew how he had to reach mean
he did and then finally after however
long they were just done and it settled
and it wasn't anything like it's so hard
to explain but it wasn't anything creepy
like you would imagine on a Hollywood
movie like Donald and Dawn just took
turns reading scripture in a totally
normal voice just like and at one point
like Donald said oh you will come out of
her and another one came up and a like
there was no like you know what I mean
it was just pure the power of Jesus
scripture prayer Jesus period and then
yeah after a while they were all just
gone and like this true peace that'll
not like a feeling of peace it was
different not like this like the feeling
of peace from meditation are from yoga
just this deep like peace of the war
it's just like ah like a peace that
passes all understanding I was raised a
Christian I've never physically seen
this have you guys physically seen or
heard anything
talking to you or anything like this I
mean this is this this is this is gnarly
I mean that that that some people
experience this in this way but what I
think is even crazier is like how how
each one came out and and it's like they
announced their names like this is this
is what got me into you and this is what
got me into you and praise God for that
couple and the way that they handled
that I mean what what what a loving way
that they did that they didn't overreact
they didn't freak out I mean I would be
like that's that's that's intense but
you know God gave them the wise
decisions that they made and you know
they were able to just keep calm in that
situation and and really help out I mean
this is this is this is powerful yeah
God is just so personal like you said he
did what he needed to do to reach you
you did the same thing with me like when
when I was going through my salvation
process like he revealed little things
to me that meant something personal
needy almost like a little vision in my
mind and I think he was doing that for
you like showing you so that you
wouldn't leave away like well it could
have been the yoga
no the yoga flashed right before your
eyes so you would know specifics to stay
away from and so you could share with
others like you are now and like Scottie
said man though that couple that helped
you like that is so important that that
shows like how much of a role each of us
play that we can help lead somebody to
Christ in a huge way like you did your
lives well like they did in your life
they weren't scared like like you were
saying like they were freaked out they
were just like yeah we kind of expected
something like this like we knew what
you were involved with but don't be
afraid because Jesus have power over
this like they will you know it was just
matter of fact it wasn't it was so
refreshing to have you know that they
were gifted and that area of discernment
and being able to lead me through that
Oh
so what give me some other alternative
to yoga I mean if if somebody like you
know doesn't want to do yoga to get into
the spiritual thing is there something
else that they can do that they will
give them that same exercise yeah that's
a great question so at first I would ask
you know what is your what are you
trying to get out of yoga are you still
in the camp of exercise like I hear some
people sometimes you know like oh it's
the only thing that helps my back it's
the only thing that
Yatta Yatta fill in the blank and I
would just say guys see doesn't care
about your back like he's gonna let your
back feel better because he doesn't care
about it he cares about your soul and he
cares that you're being separated from
Jesus he cares that you're on this path
further you know taking you further away
from the Lord but yoga is not this like
miracle cure for your back what's
helping your back is the movement and
the stretch it and you can do that
outside of the
I would say you know just get a give
even a stretching book on the off of
Amazon just to learn how to do the
stretches properly I've been looking
guys for a like an alternative that I
can point people to but so far I haven't
been able to find one that I trust fully
that doesn't have like spiritual stops
of work you know inner woven so I do
have plans Lord willing we'll see on the
horizon we'll see how what the Lord has
been for I'm true tone fitness like
doing an alternative to yoga that I know
it doesn't have any spiritual
underlining that I can point people to
but if you're interested in that you can
find out on my newsletter on my website
and I can keep you posted on it as it
comes to fruition Lord willing um but I
would add I would just point you with
like just stretching walking swimming
like all of these things just like
getting in the water takes a lot of
strain off the body and just moving its
movement guys that's helping you yeah
it's not yoga it's the movement of just
moving your body and toning and
stretching and exercising and then I
would say to those of you who are like
well it helps me feel more peaceful okay
this is think that what we were talking
about like this false peace doing the
lead if that's why you're doing it you
need to be very careful and stock right
right away because you're already
getting deeper and choose the path of it
and I would say if you feel like it
relieving you to feelings of peace
listen stop your yoga practice any sort
of meditation practice stuff anything
like that and instead get up even like
10 minutes 15 minutes a half an hour as
much as you can do earlier and spend
some time pouring your heart out to the
Lord in prayer and just praying to him
talking to him you know praising him for
who he is praising him for what he's
done
thanking him you know at land your
request before him talking to him as a
friend and you know he calls himself
this has our husband he calls himself
our Shepherd he's our father he's
everything
good that nurturing you know he wants to
be our fall and like what an amazing
thing that the god of the universe wants
to be that force because you wanted to
talk to him so do that and spend some
time in his word reading scripture and
that is where you know that's the Lord's
instruction is for us for for deepening
our relationship with him and doing that
it's going to bring you over time in my
warm and fuzzy maybe it will but it's
not going to do the same thing in the
same way as Satan's deception but you
know what it will do is it will bring
you true peace it will bring true
healing it will reach true clarity to
all sorts of things in your life and
above all it'll deepen your relationship
with a true and living God and name of
Jesus and I think that's that's really
what we're trying to get to here guys
that's what we want if we want truth we
want a relationship that's deeper with
Jesus the Lord calls us and the
ambassadors for him we have an
obligation those about to follow Jesus
we have an obligation to represent him
well and so I would just encourage you
to take all of this up with the Lord
yourselves and just lay it before him
and just ask him to reveal truth to you
and then seek his word and what he would
have you do and you know we trust him
and we'll just pray we'll just be
praying for you that the Lord continues
to a revealer through to you I have a
question because this comes up a lot
with yoga what about Pilates yeah that's
a great question I do know that Joseph
Pilates who found a body said long with
the yoga instructor so I know that you
took a lot from his mom and from yoga so
I just don't recommend it for the reason
alone again I've never done it so I
don't know 100% but anything that has a
connection with yoga I'm just not
comfortable
it's like draw a line in the sand and
don't say how close you can get to the
edge you know walk the other way yeah
yeah that's very wise counsel I've seen
that come up too and I didn't exactly
know what to say so that's I'm glad that
you address that I did pilatus I've done
it but I don't know I didn't maybe I'm
just not aware or because I just did it
out of YouTube video it seems like it's
just exercise yeah but I'm not sure yeah
don't take me I make it make you think
about it yeah well Jessica thank you so
much for you know giving us your
expertise in this topic and you know
we'd love to explore more I'm sure you
have more stories but thank you so much
for your time and thank you everybody
for watching if you guys have any
suggestions comments I mean definitely
leave them in the comment section below
if you want to reach Jessica we'll put a
link into her website and you can
communicate with her through that and
also we have a book deal so we're gonna
do a book giveaway for Jessica's a book
so make sure you check out that out in
the link below it will take you to our
website you can register put in your
email for the free book offer and we
will select a winner and it could be you
so check it out we'll see you next time
this has been LED live
[Music]